大家好,我是青龙君,欢迎来到我们今天的专题课程
很多人在进行股票交易的过程当中总是乱乱买卖,导致自己的账户持续亏损
其根本的原因就是对股价的量价值之甚少
如何才能找到一个个股最经典的买卖点呢?
今天我就给大家介绍一个非常经典的通过量价来预判股票买卖点的方法
一个极少人知道的OBV经典买卖绝技
第一次听课的朋友可以关注我的频道
长期的来收听我的内容
今天的课程大概需要15分钟
建议大家把本视频先收藏下来
以便于今后反复的来复习
好了我们开始今天的课程
今天我们重点给大家要解决的是股票买卖点的问题
今天讲的这个方法是OBV经典买卖绝技
可能很多人对于OBV的理解非常少
今天我就深入浅出
给大家专门来讲一下
OBV经典买卖的绝技
本绝技呢
我依然把它放在了我的青春君锦囊妙技当中
供大家长期的来学习
我们先来看这样一个个股
这个股票啊
从最低的价格
30多块钱最高涨到了116
而就在最近呢
出现了大幅的下跌
这种股票其实最关键的就是如何知道股票买卖点
大家请看
这样的图片我们看得很清楚
在股价没有上涨之前蜡烛比较小
而当股价涨起来之后
在上方出现了大量的阳线和阴线
说明这种关系呢
完全是成交量和股价之间形成的一个顶部
股市当中最基本的四个要素
量价时空
也是组成了股价不断运行的标准
那么如何通过成交量来精准的找到股价的买卖点呢
而通过成交量去找到买卖点
有一个非常经典的指标
它的名字就叫做OBV
好我们来介绍一下这个指标
OBV这个指标呢
又称为能量潮
叫做成交量
进额指标
它是把成交量数量化
这个能量潮啊
又称为平衡交易量
它的理论基础是
能量是因股价是国
量在价先
而把这样的指标
跟我们的图表配合起来
来找到市场的氛围
也就是当人气旺的时候呢
这个市场
它想上的概率就大
所以把这个OBV这个指标
我们把成交量数量化之后
就可以精准的推测市场的人气
这个指标呢
有两条线组成
第一条线是白色的这根线呢
是OBV线
专门是把成交量数量化
黄色的这条线呢
是OBV线的均线
它的参数呢
是34
关于OBV的详细设置
我已经把它放在了我的青春君技能妙技当中
供大家来学习
好了
我们今天呢
要给大家介绍非常经典的OBV这个指标
关于买卖点的六大方法
每一个方法都非常非常的实用
接下来就由我有潜入深的给大家进行讲解我们先来看这样一个股票这个股票呢在前期有相当长的时间出现了盘整就在最近连续的拉伸
而这种拉伸的力度啊
也是很大的
我们可以看得很清楚
当股价在这个底部形成大量的筑底之后呢
股价形成了暴涨
我们先来看一下这个时间
有很多大量的股票
它的时间是现在底部盘整的时间比较长
少则两个月多则半年
经过这样大量的筹码盘整之后
股价出现了拉伸
那么根据我们传统的方法
当股价连续盘整的时候
我们是不能入场的
因为这个时候我们不知道这个股票究竟有没有主力要拉伸的动向
怎么才能知道股价的拉伸呢
这就通过OBV
你发现当股价在连续盘整的同时
下方
OBV一直在均线的下方
说明这个时候的人气啊
并不旺盛
而就在这个位置
也就是股价出现了一根大阳线
这一天
一根大阳线
而这个大阳线呢
其实也没有突破前期的这个高点
这根大阳线的出现
精准的是下方
OBV这个线
突破了均线
而就在此时此刻
下方的成交量
出现了放量
我们一直讲
成交量在任何情况下
都是非常重要的
你发现成交量的放量
它的放量的力度
是之前成交量的两倍
这就是非常经典的放量
而放量之后
股价在当天
你发现在放量的这一天
股价出现了大幅的拉升
而在拉升的同时
对应了一根中央
OBV这个指标
上穿了均线
而下方的成交量放量
这时候有人在问他说
这里是不是也上穿了呢
你看这里上穿的同时
下方成交量并不是放大
并没有出现双倍量的一个增加
所以这个第一个买点的方法
我们来总结一下
当OBV指标持续横盘
超过两个月的时候
记住很多在底部做盘的股票都会出现这种心态
多方可能已经积累了充足的力量
此后一旦OBV指标向上突破
就形成看涨买入信号
当股价还没有创出新高之前
我们就提前知道了这个股票的最佳买卖点
所以量在价先说的就是这个道理
这是我们看到的第一个
再来看这第二个
这个股票呢是属于超跌反弹的股票
根据我们讲到的方法
当股价在连续下跌的时候
你看下方的OBV
白色的这根线一直在均线的下方
此时我们不需要介入
那么我们在介入的时候
刚才讲到的方法
在突破的时候就是一个介入点
那么如何才能做到
在突破的位置就是一个非常绝佳
非常安全的一个买点呢
此时我们来看一下这个图表
这个图表你首先发现
股价呢是在持续的创新低
从这个位置跌到了最低价
三块五毛七
而下方OBV底部呢
是在持续的创新高
这就是非常经典的底部的背离
也叫做底背离底背离啊往往是一种看涨的信号当底背离出现之后这个股票随即就出现了大幅的拉伸
在这个位置
你看下方OBV上穿黄线
这就是一个非常经典的买入
买入这个股票上涨的概率就大大提升
而你发现这个OBV已经拐头想上
我们来总结一下
当股价下跌的时候
如果OBV指标上涨
就形成OBV指标的底背离
也就是经典的看涨买入信号
这是今天给大家讲到的第二个看涨
再来看一下第三个
这个图表呢
从图表的走势啊
我们看到这个股票在最近下跌的力度很大
那么这种股票我们如何才能在高位卖出呢
首先这个股票在连续上涨的时候
你发现下方OBV这条线
一直在均线
也就是OBV的均线之上
说明是安全的
那么当股价跌回均线
这肯定是一个卖出的位置
我们怎么来预判呢
你发现当股价在顶部连续创新高的同时
下方OBV这条线
跟上方的股价呢
就形成了经典的顶背离
顶背离啊
往往是看跌的信号
所以你看
当这一个位置
也就是OBV这条线下穿均线的位置
也是当时最高价的第一天第二天
最高价的第二天就出现了一个卖出的信号
那么相对来说卖出的这个点呢
也是相对在高位
总结一下当股价上涨的时候
如果OBV指标下跌
就形成了OBV指标顶背力
这是看跌卖出的信号
所以大家先记住
这个顶背离当出现的时候
因为就是成交量跟股价的一种背离
把这种关系反映在图表上
我们可以更清楚的知道接下来的变化
好了我们再看第四个类型
这个类型呢
是我今天要讲的重点
很多股票在经过持续横盘之后
突然拉升
而在拉到高位之后
你发现急速下进
今天我要讲的是
你看一下这一根线
这根线是当股价在连续拉伸的同时
这天收了一个大阴线
这根大阴线下方成交量倍增
与此同时这个OBV也跌破了均线
这个位置就是一个非常经典的卖出
所以当股价创新高
你发现OBV如果急转直下
大家请看
实际上这一天9块2毛5这个价格
当天股价是创了新高的
但是当天很清楚的发现
OBV急转之下
这个股票在此时就形成了一个卖出的信号
一个非常经典的在高位卖出的一个方法
再来看下一个
大家请看这个个股
这个股票也是我们很多人会看到这样的股票
你发现这种股票就是大涨大跌
而随着现在盘面的变化
大涨大跌的股票非常多
那么通过OBV这个诈法
就可以更早的知道
如何在高位提前卖出
大家请看
这是一根线
这一根线的下方
OBV当时是不是走平的
是走平股价创了新高
但是OBV走平
就在第二天
你发现第二天股价创新高
但是OBV是急转直上记住是急转直上同样是创新高但是OBV在这一天表现很不寻常急转说明这个时候就是短期顶部已经出现
千万记住
股价跟OBV是平稳的走就对了
但是如果出现这种急转向上
那往往是主力在高位出货的一个动作
我们来总结一下
当OBV指标加速上涨的时候
如果股价上涨的速度没有加进
你发现股价也在涨
但当街是跌下来了
对不对
股价没有跟进
往往是看跌的信号
这就是我们通过这个方法
第一时间就找到了卖点
再来看今天的最后一个方法
这个方法呢
我们要讲的是
股价在连续涨的同时
你要记住股价的上涨
与此同时下方的OBV
也应该是缓慢的上行
这种往往是比较稳定的
也就告诉我们这种匀速的一种上涨
对于股价的稳定性有很大的作用
所以这种股票呢
你就持股就好了
两边的速度是同步的
所以当OPV指标和股价一起上涨的时候
表示市场正处在良性的上涨区间
这就是上涨趋势还将继续的信号
今天我给大家讲了六个
关于OBV两条线的设置
我依然把它放在了我的青春军技能妙计当中
供大家长期的来学习
好了我们总结一下今天的课程
今天我们要讲的是OBV经典的买卖绝技
这一个绝技呢
我们今天给大家讲到了六大绝技
首先第一个是横盘突破看涨买入
当OBV指标持续横盘超过两个月的时候
多方可能已经积攒了充足的力量
此后一旦OBV指标想象突破
就形成看涨买入信号
这是第一个
第二个底背离看涨买入
当股价下跌的时候
OBV这个指标是上涨
形成了OBV指标的底背离
记住是底背离
这就是看涨买入的信号
再看第三个是顶背离看跌买出
当股价上涨
而OBV这个指标是持续下跌
就形成OBV指标的顶背力
这是看跌卖出的信号
下一个是新高急转
当股价连创新高
但是OBV急转直下
跌破OBV的均线
就是看跌卖出的信号
第五个
涨速不均看跌卖出
当OBV指标加速上涨的时候
如果股价上涨的速度没有加快
就形成了看跌卖出信号
这是第五个
最后一个我们谈到的是同时上涨继续看涨
当OBV指标和股价一起上涨的时候
表示市场处在良性上涨区间
就是上涨趋势还将继续的信号
这就是我今天给大家讲到的OBV非常经典的方法
相信通过本方法呢
大家应该对于股票的买卖点有了一定的了解
我今天的内容呢就给大家分享到这里
如果你喜欢我的视频
欢迎大家持续的关注点赞
加留言
更多炒股干货等你掌握
如果你对今天的视频
你有什么疑问
欢迎大家在评论区跟我留言
谢谢大家
股市有风险
入市需谨慎
以上观点
仅供参考